Galaxy 5000, racing in the 51st century, the best racing in the universe.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
And I'm Sean. Is this like a method of future proofing your game so that we can't prove that this doesn't happen?
Yeah, I'd say like, you know, giving yourself a good 4000 years, you know, maybe 3000 and change is a pretty good way to make sure no one can say you were wrong.
Right. I mean, we've seen with Back to the Future that like, you know, even in 1985, it's not a good idea to say what happens in 2015.
Like that's gonna happen soon.
We're gonna, you know, like we're not that far away.
And then it did pass and those things didn't happen.
Not unless you knew that something pretty bad was gonna happen in 2012, which I think we all know came true.
Right, right, right, right.
So the Mayans tried this long shot thing.
And even they, you know, had to experience that, you know, time will pass.
And so theoretically, there is a world where people are listening to this very episode, Sean, in the year 5000.
Is there something you want to say to them?
Um, I'm gonna say I'm gonna have a few questions.
My first question is, did we ever get Half Life 3?
And the second would be, can I come?
That's amazing.
The first question is kind of funny, though, because you have to imagine that if at any point, we got Half Life 3 before the year 5000, that like they also just went on a rip after that.
And it was like, yeah, four, five, six, and seven are all coming out like within years of each other after Half Life 3.
It's like, just took a really long time to figure out that third one.
But now we are just busting through them.
And so that's like a bizarre question to someone.
Yeah. In the year 5000.
Or if I were to ask, did the Bills ever win the Super Bowl?
And then they just say, like, actually, there was a civilization ending asteroid impact.
So American football hasn't been played in 3000 years.
And the Bills didn't win one before that.
And that's just what I think is going to happen.
I think that that's a full possibility.
And unfortunately, they probably can't even understand our language in the year 5000.
So we should really be saying, gleek gloop glabagoober.
Oh, I like that better.
Right. It is in the year 5000.
They're not even like talking in the same kinds of ways.
No, no, no. Consonants, vowels.
That's not a thing anymore.
Right. Exactly. The, you know, those noises when you go between worlds in this video game, Galaxy 5000.
Yeah, that's the, that's their actual language.
They're predicting that. Yeah.
Right. They predicted that.
That's their first prediction that they're the Nostradamus of video games.
If you haven't picked up yet, Galaxy 5000 is, uh, it, not only does it take place in the
future, it takes place in the 51st century, uh, where armored turbo craft racing is the, uh, sport of choice for thrill seeking individuals.
And, uh, you start in the minor leagues on Mercury and try to work your way through the solar system.
Uh, I guess that means that Pluto is the big leagues, but, uh, I guess this is their first mistake unless Pluto continues to be become a planet once again, but Pluto is not a planet anymore.
So shouldn't it be ended at Neptune?
Uh, I mean, I guess you can just have these things happen on any kind of like planet toyd.
Um, maybe, maybe they have a Grand Prix on series that we're not aware of that just isn't in this game, you know?
And, you know, the game isn't selling a deep story.
Uh, you know, I was joking about like the minor leagues and stuff like that.
It's just selling a vibe, you know, space racing prize money to fix your ship and blowing up your competitors.
So it is kind of like combat vehicle racing in a way that we haven't, I mean, we've had it, but like not in the, not in the way that this game is doing it, where it kind of, this is like if RC Pro-Am was like thrown into outer space, added some jumps and, uh, did a, maybe RC Pro-Am had digitized voices, but there is a digitized voice in this game, which is pretty cool.
It's like, get out of here.
Right. The most important thing that's going to make or break any racing game, but specifically one that takes the RC Pro-Am isometric approach and puts it in space is how it feels to drive one of these bad boys.
Sean, is it fun to drive one of these spacecrafts?
I'm going to go out on a limb and say yes.
Uh, I think that that basic vibe, that, that basic feel from RC Pro-Am is there.
Uh, I just have a soft spot for isometric games in the first place.
And even though this game doesn't have like a, like a, the typical feel of a racer, like there's no accelerate button.
It's just the direction you push is the direction you go.
Yeah. But it also like, you have to take into account that the direction you push is also going to feel an amount of, uh, momentum.
So it's also sort of like you're nudging it in that direction instead of actually going in that direction.
It's kind of complex when you think about it, but when you actually push the buttons, it's very intuitive.
Uh, it's just a little, you gotta get the hang of it is all.
Yeah. And it's not like this hard to read, uh, 3D depth that we've seen with other games that try to do 3D because it's the isometric and we're kind of used to it at this point.
Uh, it is, it is kind of like easy to tell when they're going to be turns.
Uh, they're not just like sudden, uh, you know, all of a sudden a blinker on your left saying, okay, you're going to start turning left now.
And then it's like a hard turn.
Like we've seen in mock rider and games like that.
I feel like visually the course, even when they do get more complicated with actual like gaps and obstacles in the course themselves, it's still a readable thing that makes it easy to, uh, understand how to, how to drive these things.
You know, if you do have to take it slow or, or bank a turn or something like that.
The interesting part of course comes not just from the racing, but the combat aspect because it's four ships racing at once and you can shoot your rival ships.
You can destroy track obstacles.
You have to jump over certain obstacles or pits.
Um, otherwise you might fall off the course or take too much damage, taking damage during the races.
Even if you successfully finish the race means that, uh, you will have to use some of your winning money, uh, your prize money to heal your ship or else you run the risk of permanently damaging your ship.
That, that combat aspect is something that we haven't seen mixed with, um, these other like RC pro am style racing games.
Um, or, you know, we've seen on some of the ones that are trying to do like a simulation, we've seen some sort of, uh, buying parts and stuff like that.
But this game takes it to, um, uh, maybe a more arcadey level.
Yeah. Like you're not really upgrading anything.
You're, you're more so getting pretty impressive, like cosmetic damage onto your rig that you see between each race.
And then you can choose to repair yourself and it kind of just like, it kind of wipes over the damage and you just, you get a clean new ride.
Um, I'm not really sure how it affects like your stats or speed or whatever, because I always just completely repaired whatever vehicle I had between races.
I don't really know what happens if you've kind of let it pile up.
Yeah. I got to imagine that, uh, not only will you eventually just get a game over if you, if your money can't repair your ship, uh, because it is the kind of thing where like your money is based on your placing.
So you don't have to finish in first to move on.
You just have to finish at all because the actual, um, the actual track itself is a part of the, of the pressure of the game.
Um, there's a clock that is counting down from, I don't know if it's always the same, but it's like, you got like basically two and a half minutes.
Um, and when that timer runs out, especially like at the last three seconds, like the course just kind of fades out.
Like the space obviously remains now you're going to dark.
It's just the whole course disappears.
Yeah. Raises some questions about the designs of these courses in general.
Like, are these just projections with some kind of solid state to them so that they could hard light that they could handle?
Yeah. Right. Uh, but, but once that time is up, like that's it.
So if you didn't cross the finish line, you can cross the finish line, like red at the end and still count it as a, as moving on.
But if you don't, it's, it's, you know, that's the end of, uh, the race.
So you have to complete these, not only, uh, in a good time to get, uh, the completion of the course, but in a good place to get enough money to repair, uh, your ship as well.
Yeah. And it is an interesting moment.
Like when you get to that point where it just starts to fade away, cause it is gradual.
It happens over, uh, like the last five, six seconds.
So it, I think it's more so they turn the lights off.
I think the, I think the track is still there.
Um, but yeah, you'd have to, it gets a little bit harder to actually finish, but I'm sure it's for some people created some pretty dramatic finishes.
Um, how, how did you perform in the game?
Um, you know, at first I was performing pretty great.
Uh, I didn't have that much trouble learning, um, the driving, uh, aspect.
And especially, uh, because the game lets you, uh, you can take jumps in a way where like, if there is a, a curve, but the curve meets back up in a specific way, you could take a long enough jump that you just skipped the whole bend and go to the next part of the track.
And at first the computers won't think to do stuff like that.
And so it's very easy to kind of just like, uh, skip parts of the track shortcuts, if you will, but intentional, the game wants you to do that kind of stuff to, to place first, uh, early on.
Once the, like amount of obstacles and the amount of turns, uh, in the game increased, which happens, uh, pretty early on when even, even as soon as you get to like, uh, Venus or Mars, uh, then it got a little trickier to finish in first, but not to like complete the course.
Yeah. Yeah.
So I do think the game is forgiving in, in that front.
Yeah.
I also think that I appreciate that.
Not every, not every, uh, NPC knows all of the shortcuts.
Like they definitely do have them programmed in.
So they're just going to do them and you might learn of them by watching them do it, but you also might be the first to find them, uh, in your race.
And sometimes they'll go the long way around.
So it's not like you're facing off against optimization opponents here.
And you don't want the money just to repair your current ship.
You want the money. So this way you can buy, uh, the other ships in the game and, uh, upgrade, uh, the ships appropriately.
There are five different models.
There's the Tomahawk, the Crusher, the Phantom, the Scorpion, and the Stiletto.
Uh, so naturally you don't want to just be using all your money to repair damage from the ship, which I guess if you played recklessly enough, you could just have like a lot of damage at the end of each one.
Again, I don't think, especially in the earlier stages, that that would be something that would happen to you unless you were truly just careless.
Yeah. Uh, but you know, as you want to progress and continue to get these better ships, uh, you'll, you'll need to do so.
And they got pretty cool designs too.
I mean, the naming convention is pretty, you know, there's a lot to be desired there.
I feel like you don't want to fly in the crusher.
I feel like crusher is, is something that you come up with when you're eight and then you just don't really think about it again.
And you have to say it like crusher that, that and Scorpion, which I think like, you know, Scorpion is cool.
Scorpion was moral combat.
Yeah. You know what I'm going to say.
But like, these are default cool middle school boy names.
Right. Right.
But the designs of the ships themselves are, uh, are pretty cool in terms of like what, uh, I mean, they're not like aerodynamic because you're, you know, you're in space and that doesn't matter.
Do you think that's also why there aren't like cool noises for accelerating?
Like. Like there's no sound in space.
I know there's no sound in space.
I know. I know. I'm, I'm just coming up with probably the answer they came with when they were about to ship the game.
And, uh, I think Activision was the publisher.
Oh, they were also the developers.
So it was like, they're talking to each other and they're like, shouldn't there be some more sounds?
No, it's fine.
We're being scientifically accurate here.
Uh, but that's like the only thing that I found very like weird about the, like the, the, the feel of the races.
Like when I was thinking of, does this have a sense of speed?
I felt like, yes, it does.
But the sound design is not doing anything for that.
It's just in the handling and visually moving the screen fast.
There are two, uh, control schemes too, which I thought was a little strange.
And did you try the, the alpha controls are the ones that first off alpha controls, of course, I'm not a beta.
I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna deal with that, but like the alpha controls, it's like pretty normal stuff.
You know, you use the D pad to steer in the directions that the, that you need to steer the whole game in.
And functionality. Yeah.
Right. And the beta controls, all of a sudden I was like, what does it want me to do here?
Like I'm using up to accelerate and down to slow down the vehicle.
Like that's how I'm, I'm dealing my speed.
But then I have to use this.
It's a D pad people.
It's not an analog stick.
It's not too analog. Yeah, but it's like, it's tank controls.
That's how we played RC Pro-Am.
That's how, really?
I'm almost positive.
No, I know. I'm saying like, I didn't go back and revisit it.
So it just felt strange after coming, because I started with the alpha controls to then go to the beta controls.
I was like, eh, I don't know about this.
I wasn't a fan of it.
Yeah. I mean, I preferred, uh, the, I think that if it didn't have the kind of like the weight, if, if the characters of the characters, if the vehicles didn't have the kind of weight that they do, I would have preferred tank controls, but they are kind of weighty.
So you're always, you're always kind of like trying to micro, micro steer.
So I didn't really think the tank controls were necessary, but maybe some people, that's the only way that they can think.
Well, the manual goes as far as to say that the beta controls are harder to get the hang of, but once you master them, they'll help you place better in the later runs.
Yeah. That tracks.
That makes sense.
I mean, I would imagine you have a lot more, uh, you have a lot more like acute control over the angle at which you are driving as compared to the isometric viewpoint.
Um, it reminds me of like any game, like any Gran Turismo where like when you finally go to manual mode instead of automatic transmission and it's like, Oh, like I, I can do a lot better.
Like even, even the licenses in Gran Turismo are like designed to be really hard if you're using automatic transmission.
Cause I don't think you can get gold on some of them.
Is it even driving if you're using automatic?
That's so European of you.
Yeah. I've never learned how to drive stick.
So. Yeah.
It's funny because I, I did learn how to drive manual for Gran Turismo games, but I still would never want to put myself in a car with like, I feel like something you need to learn inside and outside of a video game.
It's not, it doesn't apply.
It doesn't move over.
What? I could definitely command a, like an army in, in the middle ages because I played, I've played Crusader Kings.
So come on. Right.
And we both tried a little bit of steel battalion.
So we're totally ready to control a futuristic tank.
That's true. That's true.
...! the single player mode with you know nine planets four races per planet four laps per race like it's
a long game yeah i didn't finish it it's not asking you to do anything different each time
though like they the the stages do become more complex for the people for the people who want
to complete it right it's not just okay here's the next crazy design we came up with it's like they
do add different kinds of obstacles they do have uh larger and longer tracks with bigger shortcuts
that you kind of need to discover through uh through trial and error it's a bad feeling to
miss a jump in this game by the way uh and it can happen you could just like misread the line because
the even if the tiniest part of your ship like touches any part of the course it like counts
it as like you landing so it is like sometimes kind of forgiving so you think you're gonna make
these jumps and you start to get like riskier and riskier and then one time you just don't make it
yeah um and i also felt like just in in terms of like the physics of the game that in certain
levels in which there's like walls like later there aren't as many walls and you're just
more free to fall into i guess miles to the whatever planet you're uh racing above but when
there are walls there's like a lot of friction like it's if you hit it at like a weird angle you'd think
like oh you're just gonna kind of scratch off of it you're gonna lose some you're gonna lose some
velocity but you're still going mostly in the same direction but if you run into those walls
in the game you will kind of go to a full stop and you'll watch as second and third place
whiz right by you and uh yeah sometimes it can feel a little a little off the rails there
now here's the crazy question should the uh should ammo have ammunition that you need to acquire
on the track or should it have is the unlimited the way to go i think that it it's so like scattershot
it's kind of hard to aim especially when you get into like arced projectiles that you don't really
have any fine control over uh i think it's fine that that is just unlimited ammo like you're not
really doing you're not doing massive damage unless later there's a weapon that actually blows up cars
but is that the case no no i i guess i'm just thinking that even even if your opponents had it too
it is something that adds like a little bit more of a calculation to the races of just like up i i
i i can't just like fire at every single uh obstacle in my way every turret every uh you know laser
gate i can't shoot those things just because they're in my way i need to make sure i have the
proper ammunition for them i i would think then if they were gonna go that route you would have to have
them actually like they should be able to take out an enemy if you're gonna have limited ammo um so
then you also have to like balance it on do i want to take out one of my competitors or do i want to
take out this turret that always seems to get me on this corner uh you it would have to be like
either you get four shots in the entire race or you can just spam it and doesn't really do much
and there are a few bonuses on on the stage there i guess where i would have put the ammunition
uh collectibles uh different stars and uh the green star just adds money to your account the red star
uh gives a little repair to the damage on your aircraft but the blue star gives you a special
weapon and a second blue star gives you rapid fire so it's really that blue star that you want but any
of these are good things to pick up and at first they just kind of seem like okay yeah that's just
something i could handle with money but it does give you a reason to just maybe like go off the
line yeah yeah like leave the clean racing line because it's like all right well at the very least
if i collect this i might um you know like i might i might get the bonus uh or or offset the damage that
i might have taken there they needed maybe more purposeful placement of these stars like to teach you
shortcuts or something like oh if i if i just like if they were in the pits where technically if you had
the right momentum or swing to it you could reach the next thing it's like the game needed to teach
these shortcuts to the novice player in some way and i think that could have been one way they handled
it but then doesn't that also it's just sort of like a positive reinforcement like let's say you are
playing against another person uh the person that knows the shortcut also gets the power up
and yeah kind of throw a balance there i don't know right no it's true in this game these kinds of
games are gonna last based on their uh multiplayer so you do yeah you do need to to count for that
and this game does have multiplayer which is great um it is weird though yep yeah it is weird because
there's you know well it's a hard thing and always right to think about like okay how are these eight
bit racing games going to handle uh two racers at once because when i grew up playing racing games on
the n64 you know it was uh split screen was just like the the most obvious thing mm-hmm doesn't happen
here uh yeah they basically and you know it makes sense in like in a beat them up or shoot them up or
something like you die no no no you actually know it's the opposite you just get teleported from the
back if you're about to get if you're about to get uh sort of not lapped but if the other player is
about to go a full screen length ahead of you you're going to get warped to the front and it does sort of
disallow any kind of like real skill difference um it's kind of a handicap that's always going to be
there but i guess like you can kind of counter that by just counting how many times you get
teleported i don't know you gotta do that by hand and it's not like the two things aren't related to
each other but the the solve that the game has is is that the winner isn't determined by who wins the
most amount of races over the over the four right so it's not like oh if you won three if there's no chance
it's about the total points that you get and so you get points by especially on these uh when you
when you're when you're passing the screens that the second player has to basically be uh pulled forward
so that the race can continue the the person in the lead is gaining points that entire time so that
helps like oh further strengthen their lead over over the opponent so there there can be swings there
in a way that just like winning races can't i see interesting so that helps even like you know
yeah with combat and things that you blow up and everything so there's more to it than just like
finishing in first because you're both getting a time bonus for completing you're both getting
bonuses for destroying things like i do appreciate that they didn't just make it uh a best of four
yeah or what is that called because the best of seven requires you to win four so what is it what is a
in four races is that a best of three no because best of three is five no you can't have a series
with an even amount of maximum games yes that's true right because then you could just tie unless
you wanted ties to be a thing yeah yeah nobody wants ties it's a very european thing i know i don't i
know even how do you feel about that in like hockey ties uh i prefer a tie than a shootout win but
okay i uh i don't think that i like playoffs because they they force actual drama um if you're
gonna win a whole series i'm sorry if you're gonna win a whole league i don't think that um
uh any kind of trophy should be given because some other team lost to somebody that wasn't competing
like what happens in like premier league football sometimes so there you go it's weird yeah it's true
it depends on i guess what you grew up with right baseball you can't tie there's no such thing as a
tie in baseball i i really like that you can't even tie you can't tie at all even during like the
regular season they'll just make those yeah yeah exactly yeah we'll just we'll play i mean i've
some of the longest games ever are are like two and a half regular baseball games
there was no direct sequel or even a franchise follow-up to this game this is just a one-off
from activision which is interesting because like activision's a big name they could have looked for
galaxy 5000 to be like i could see that this translating well from like nes to super nintendo
to n64 right like this could have been a franchisable thing i mean yeah they they did the prequel
the prequel band what's the prequel yeah galaxy 4000 no no galaxy 500 was the prequel oh the band yeah
yeah you have to imagine that there's gotta be some connection there like yeah who came first yeah
is it the chicken which is galaxy 5000 or the egg obviously the galaxy 500 band is based off of the
video game where do you stand on that whole chicken or egg thing are you an egg guy
you're an egg man i'm gonna say that you know something that wasn't a chicken
laid an egg that became a chicken damn you just upset so many people all you have to do is just
say nothing you just you you're such you're not even a politician uh here's the thing even though
there is no uh direct sequel or anything and i'm sure activision has other racing games i could look for
i just want to talk about some of the nes ones because like you know rc program is the obvious
thing but i also got like some cobra triangle vibes oh yeah especially with the combat stuff yeah that
was a good game that was a that was sort of like a like a tasting menu of vehicles right wasn't that
like a bunch of vehicles yeah yeah exactly you were in a boat i mostly remember the boat
uh and then you know when you think about racing in the future i guess there's like there's two
different paths to go on i mean there's plenty of other futuristic racing games but usually it's
wipeout and f-zero uh and those are like the the the futuristic racing games that come to my mind
anything i missed that's obvious sean uh there's the original xbox launch title quantum redshift
i i do know quantum redshift actually uh it's funny i must have owned that at one point because
why else would i know it was on like a demo demo oh okay maybe i did have the demo disc from like
xbox magazine or something uh but you know since i mentioned f-zero i've been on a bit of an f-zero
kick lately i started with the super nintendo game uh and that was fun for a little bit but uh
leave something to be desired and so it was recommended for me next to go to play f-zero x on the
n64 i'm a big n64 guy man was i just like completely surprised by this game i can't believe something
like this works on n64 hardware there's 30 racers on the track there's no like i mean there is some
slowdown but there's barely any to like impact the gameplay it feels awesome it's got this awesome
rock and roll music the whole time it's way more exciting than the like the sense of speed is there
compared to the super nintendo game but also like there is combat in that game in fact one of the
ways to even attempt winning in f-zero games is to just destroy your opponent so that they finish in
dead last in the race and because like there is kind of that mario kart rubber banding going on where
like the guy like they kind of have their winners set up for each grand prix yeah but the guy in like
second you know he's if you don't kill him he's just going to continuously finish in the second if
you keep finishing in first but the one time you take him out that's like it now there's like a new
guy who's gonna be like all right now this is the guy this is your new rival and they mark them on the
screen as like rival kind of cool interesting and and exciting uh unfortunately i hit a wall in f-zero x and
i um i can't beat the expert mode but i did do everything that you can do in novice and standard so i'm pretty
happy so i'm just surprised that you a uh a big nintendo guy hasn't really played f-zero on the
n64 until now like that i believe for me but not you didn't even didn't even know what it might look
like sean and i'm just so blown away by the presentation that i think it is easily now
like definitely top 10 might even be top 5 n64 games well there aren't many of those so i get it
yeah that is true that is true and i i heard good things about uh the gamecube uh version of f-zero
f-zero gx so uh maybe someday i'll get around to that as well so here's the question because i was
talking about f-zero wipeout you mentioned quantum redshift is galaxy 5000 ahead of its time at all
like is it a cool idea trapped in the in in the nes and like that they could have continued
to follow up on or was this like exactly what it needed to be yeah i don't think this is ahead of
its time at all because i think it's very derivative of rc pro-am already so i it's just got a different
coat of paint they got rid of the engine sound so you could hear the music better um that's what i'm
gonna go for go with now um i think they they added a lot of cool like touches uh to make it
like sell better not like actually just to sell the space thing better like all the close-ups of the
vehicles of the ships uh those are cool but i wouldn't say that any part of it was ahead of its time
right and now that you've answered that sean i just have one more question for you
but it's kind of an important one it's the essential games list
that's not a that's not a question well now the question's gonna start okay okay big guy the
question is galaxy 5000 is it essential yeah just going off of what i just said i mean i guess that
was a poorly timed answer to a question um i i think that this is fun uh i really like the i think
it's got a good sense of speed i i think that the car combat or vehicle vehicular combat is a cool
part of it i don't think it's as as like it's not as sort of part of the game as i would like in a car
combat game um but it is cool that's there i'd say that this is a very solid play it not quite
essential just because of how kind of it's just rc pro am in space so not essential but great and
yeah i think i'm gonna echo that i mean it is one of the more distinctive racing games on the nes
i think the con the the combination of the combat with the racing i i felt like i was doing like even
though it was just uh sean you mentioned this one point in the episode just like you can just fire
whenever you want and it it doesn't have like great accuracy so you're just kind of firing all the time
but it did make the con it did make me think of this more of a combat racer than just something
especially because like you don't have to come in first yeah i like that about this game too
so i think it's not the controls or the isometric perspective that become the barrier for the game
and it's 36 races of basically the same kind of thing over and over again so i think it's not
it's not necessarily doing anything wrong it's just not taking it to that next level on anything
it's a serviceable game and it gets done what it wanted to do so i think this is like a if i bought
this in 1991 it'd be a happy purchase i'd be happy to have like friends over and do some multiplayer
but it's not one like i would personally keep going back to or think about as i got like my super nintendo
racing games in this you know in the same way like it's like okay cool now i got 16 bet technology and
all this stuff is better than it was on the nes version yeah you're gonna be way too busy with off-road
the baja that i mean like i know you grew up with that but like when i played that at the long
island retro gaming convention i was that's another one i was like blown away i was like we can do this
on the super nintendo like it's just mode seven but it like works it like it totally gets the idea
in the way that like some of these like what isometric is trying to do for like 3d on an 8-bit
platform like yeah it is it probably did blow the minds of kids but it doesn't like it doesn't hold
up to the same like tech feat that the uh that the mode seven stuff does that's true and i do want to
just give this game one last credit on the uh the amount i'm not not so much the animation itself but
just how many like different sprites your the vehicles have like not just turning but also like
how how tight the turn is like it looks really great when you're when you're moving this vehicle
around um but it's not enough for me to change the vote it's just i just wanted to give it that last
shout out there you're giving galaxy 5000 her flowers that's right i have to give her lots of flowers
because we're putting her in the grave
it's over uh i mean like let's be real we're never going to reconsider this so this is it for galaxy
5000 we're not going to let joe get in the way of this he can still vote all right galaxy 5000 go to
the polls it's jover
you